the story that i'm going to tell today
has to do with being caught on an
interstate highway
in a terrible
storm that involved freezing rain and
awful road conditions and quite a few
accidents trying to make my way home
in the darkness of night
and it happened in northwestern indiana
when i was living there from about 2002
to
2008 when i was
working at indiana state prison teaching
for ball state university
and
there the one destination point was
notre dame university which you know is
in south bend indiana really
far up on the northern end of the state
about centrally located
and that was on a good driving day about
an hour and a half
from where my family lives in
northwestern indiana
officially damat but actually closer to
rose lawn right on a county line road in
a pretty uninhabited
part of indiana
so normally i would you know drive up to
michigan city and then drive over after
i finished work
to notre dame to do some research and
then drive my way back home or sometimes
i would go to notre dame for conferences
or to to meet up with friends who are
working there or studying there
and as i remember it and i'm not sure
what year this
actually was it was in the 2000s
and there was some sort of
conference that i was going to i want to
say it was most likely
one of the center for ethics and culture
conferences which were you know quite a
big deal back then they had um not just
a single annual conference but a whole
bunch of other things going on
and aleister mcintyre was a fellow for
that as a matter of fact uh i had a
friend from italy who was was staying
there who also i think was a fellow i'm
not sure if it was at that that
particular time
but um
i spent a lot of time on the notre dame
campus and at the
involved in center events and the
weather was pretty bad i think you know
either it was a one-day event or it was
the last day of the conference
and i remember going to talks and like
looking outside the windows and thinking
this looks pretty bad
i could take off now or i could just
wait it you know wait until the very end
of the conference and then drive home
and i'll do that instead
and that turned out to be
you know overall
not a terrible
idea because i didn't get in an accident
or anything like that
but it was imprudent and i'll tell you
why
so
by the time that i got outside
and i was at my car um it had been
freezing rain for quite some time it was
probably about four o'clock or so and it
was it was winter time so things are
getting dark
and
you know the sky is just raining down
more freezing rain so you know i start
my car up at that time i had a ford
tourist station wagon which is actually
a replacement for yet another ford
tourist station wagon that had been
totaled in a crash that had to do with a
whole other uh snowy day
on interstate highways uh in in indiana
but so anyway i've got my my car and i'm
you know i started up and you know
get things going so the windows can
defrost and i've got my scraper out
there and i'm scraping away at the
frozen
now ice on my
windshield and the other windows and
starting to get myself comfortable and i
probably got on the road like 4 15 4 30
or something like that and road
conditions were bad
they were already bad in south bend and
in order to get home
what i needed to do was get from notre
dame university to where i would pick up
interstate 80 which is a highway that
spans the entire united states
and runs parallel with a couple other
highways for for a while so i would take
80 west
and then i would intersect uh interstate
65 and take 65 south from about gary if
you know where gary indiana
is on the map so i'd go west and then do
south and it would be mostly interstate
travel so i was like well
this is bad but how bad could it be
they're going to have the snow plows out
i'm sure they put salt down i'm sure
they're scraping i'm sure there's sand
let me just get underway
and we'll get going
one of the things i probably should have
done at that point that would have been
quite prudent would have been to stop at
a gas station and fully gas up but i
just wanted to get home so instead you
know i get on the road and i'm heading
north to where
i'll pick up i-80 and conditions are bad
already and there's already some cars
that are like stopped or off or all
sorts of other things like that going on
and then
i make it to i-80 and i'm like well this
is this is going to be okay because this
is the route that the big trucks are
taking
and that actually made things much more
dangerous so let me tell you a little
bit of a digression about interstate 80.
at that time we not only had the regular
semi trucks you know where you have a
tractor and then you have a trailer
we also have these
two or three trailer semi trucks as well
and on i-80 even on a good day if the
wind is blowing hard you can see these
things kind of you know trying to
maneuver themselves around they're
almost like trains on wheels and they're
they're kind of dangerous to all the
other traffic that's around them but
this is you know this is american
logistics we do so much stuff by trucks
so i get onto i-80 and it's already
starting to get darker the you know the
freezing rain is still coming down
sometimes snow in some parts sometimes
just rain the roads are slick
so traffic is moving slow it's not it's
not proceeding quickly
and you know there are plows out but it
doesn't seem like they're doing much
good the road you can feel it when
you're used to driving in these sorts of
conditions it's sort of like walking on
ice something that if you grow up here
in the upper midwest
you learn how to do very quickly right
you you learn what it feels like to be
on a rough patch of ice as opposed to a
very slick patch of ice you know how you
have to take these little mincing steps
well you got to do that with your car
because your car after you're used to
driving it for quite a while becomes
almost like an extension of your body
you can feel the tires and where they're
slipping and where they're gripping
instead and it was mostly slipping so
you you move slowly because you know
that it's going to take you a long time
to be able to break and you don't want
to hit other cars because if you do
things get very unpredictable very
quickly you know you're basically like
solving complex
uh math problems about acceleration and
forces in your head intuitively as
you're driving along
so you know traffic is is moving slowly
and this is before i actually had a cell
phone so i wasn't gonna be able to call
home and you know
say what was going on or anything like
that
and
i'm driving along and i'm like oh man
this is going to take a long time to get
home i bet it's going to take me
two and a half hours as opposed to the
one and a half hours that it normally
takes me
fast forward it was actually four hours
four hours for what would normally be a
one and a half hour trip home
and
you know there it was pretty harrowing
pretty scary
i-80 was
good compared to what i-65 looked like
so it took me i don't know how long
maybe
an hour and a half to get to
the interchange for
i8 from i-80 to i-65 and these
interchanges are where you you've got
these on-ramps that are kind of circular
and you got to follow it and they can be
sloped and you know if there's any sort
of gradation to it
you can feel your car on the ice
actually sliding down slowly and that's
pretty scary too because you know that
you need to keep moving in this curved
line well not curved line this this
curve right rather than a straight line
and you're like worrying about am i
actually going to get there am i going
to slide off of this on-ramp you know in
some way
and so anyway i made it on to i-65 and
now i'm like okay good i'm i'm headed
home now i've got the first part of the
journey behind me cool this is gonna be
okay and it was not okay
the wind was blowing
rain is still coming down snow in parts
you know there's uh i think i tailed the
snow plow for a while at a distance and
even the snow plot was slipping the
roads were so
completely slick that in parts we were
just moving at like you know five to ten
miles an hour
long long chains of cars and trucks
trying to maintain some distance between
each other you definitely don't want to
be up on each other's bumper at that
time it's now like completely night
and you almost can't see anything you've
got your
defrost on you got your window wipers
going back and forth constantly and
you're struggling to see what's going on
ahead of you in this this storm and you
still feel your tires sliding and
slipping and not gripping on the ice and
you're moving ahead almost like you know
saying a prayer every moment that you
don't fall off the road
and fall off the road is indeed what i
saw happen
i saw a semi truck so you know semi
truck is is
heavy compared to a car it's massive
right
and they have many more tires so they
ought to be able to
grip the road better
than a car with only four tires and
a limited amount of weight there was a
semi truck ahead of me
and we were we were
just about stopped we were moving about
five miles an hour
and i saw this semi truck
start a slow slide
and it actually i guess the road at that
point must have been you know uneven
kind of beveled
i saw this semi truck slide off of the
road like an egg coming off of a
non-stick pan
and you could tell that the driver
couldn't do
anything about it by this time
you know as you're driving along you you
passed
dozens maybe even hundreds of other cars
and semis who were off the road you know
some of whom had put their hazards on
and it just pulled off and they're like
i'm gonna wait out this this storm
others who had gotten into accidents
already or who had like gone off the
road into the median or the other side
of the road and were stuck in the snow
and you know there
it was going to be hours and hours
before tow trucks came out one of the
dangers with this is it was pretty cold
too so if you got stuck
you better hope that you had enough gas
to keep your car going to keep the heat
on because you could freeze out there
you know it might be
who knows how many hours before rescue
crews came out because there were going
to be so many people in need of help
so anyway i kept proceeding like this
down this this
ice slick road um
you know moving slowly i think the
fastest i i was going at any point was
maybe 20 miles an hour
and uh that wasn't you know a lot of it
and then um
driving past and i'm getting further and
further south and it becomes less and
less inhabited by by that point and i
get to the
place where
i have a choice to make do i turn off
from the interstate
onto
the road that would
go to lowell uh a town that's north of
roselawn and then i would take country
roads to get there
and i thought well i mean the highway is
pretty scary but
i don't know about the back roads they
may be even worse than this and at least
on the highway
i know what i've what i've got you know
in front of me
so i go past that exit and i remember i
saw somebody actually try to make that
exit and get into a crash and i was like
man i'm glad i didn't pick that
and i keep going from
that i think it's two maybe that goes
into lowell uh indiana too and i need to
get down to indiana highway 10 where i
could turn off for
dimont or rose lawn
and you know i knew that once i got
there if i could actually
make it to the on-ramp i would be more
or less okay because then i was only a
mile a mile and a half from my home if
if worse came to worse and the car
you know
went off the road i could i could walk
home along the
10 and then county line road and get
some help
by this time i'm getting kind of worried
because i since i didn't gas up i'm at
the point where i'm at empty and the you
know gas light comes on and there's
there's on american cars right you've
got the empty thing but you're not truly
empty at that point you got like maybe a
gallon or two
when the light comes on you know you're
really getting close you're you're
basically on fumes and so you know i'm
driving slowly
and
i think i was maybe i don't think i
listened to the radio at all except to
like try to hear weather stuff because i
needed all my attention
for where i'm going and now the good
thing about the off ramp
for highway 10 is highway 10 runs over
interstate 65 as opposed to lowell where
it goes underneath it so you're going up
the off ramp and then you know it comes
to a stop and then you can turn on to
10.
um and going up in many respects is
better than going down when things are
really slick i mean you could get
stalled trying to go up and as i
remember what i did i actually i i went
slightly off of the road there because i
knew that the shoulder which was paved
was rougher and so i would be able to
get more purchase there because i didn't
want to go up and then slide back down
right
so i go up and i make it there and i get
on highway 10 and highway 10 is pretty
slick but it looks like a snow plow had
gone through there recently so i was
like all right so i just got to go
less than half a mile to get to county
line road we've got to turn onto county
county line road which had not been
plowed
and then it's another half a mile north
to turn in for our driveway and i did
that
and um
you know it was it took me quite a while
to get from 10 to county line road to
our driveway and then get down
uh i i think i didn't even like try to
pull into the the garage i think i just
maybe parked outside and then got back
got myself back inside and my family was
like where were you what was going on we
didn't hear from you
and i said well you know the road
conditions were really terrible by that
time it was like you know 8 30 nine
o'clock at night
um the conference had been long over and
every i mean at that point in time too
it was a bad winter storm people were
losing power
there were you know announcements about
you know closing highways and stuff like
that
so i made it home
and that was probably
one of the worst
driving winter conditions
that i've been in except for the one
where i actually totaled my car and and
a few from the
1990s when i was uh working
up at lakeland college as a security
guard but those are stories for another
time maybe you'll get a kick out of this
story i was just reminded because
there's ice storms and
freezing rain and snow going on in other
places than than here in wisconsin and
it was reminding me of that one
terrible night when i was on the road
just hoping not to run out of gas hoping
not to go off the road hoping not to
crash hoping that i wouldn't get hit by
somebody else and i did make it home